hey what's up welcome back to my channel
my name is samuel and i'm amanda and
this is the samuel and amanda show where
we talk about money marriage and life so
i don't know what you've been up to this
week but i hope you've had a fabulous
week
also
i really think you should smash the like
button uh me and amanda do videos every
single week i do a video every single
day i've noticed myself thurman when i'm
watching other people's channels yeah i
almost feel like
if i like the video
by me liking the video i've kind of lost
something myself really
like almost like you're giving money or
something there's only so many likes you
can give
yeah
so i i kind of find myself sparingly
giving like so i think
i'll go
that was a good video though i like this
guy i like his channel and i'll go
let me just see if it's i don't think
it's very sure
um
i think other people do that but that's
really but but
i've learned that it's actually
completely stupid to think like that
because actually free it's free it
doesn't cost anything to like a video so
guys on that note
if you hit like you really haven't lost
anything in fact it just means you're
coming more of a position of abundance
and you can like and like and like and
like like every single video we'd really
appreciate that um and what you've been
up to this week
this week's been cool i've actually i
didn't tell you this but this morning i
weighed myself so if you've been
watching our podcast these videos for a
while you know that i've been trying to
lose my baby weight yeah and i'm now two
and a half pounds away from hitting my
first goal and that would be a stern so
i'm nearly there so that's really good
so that's my first interim goal and then
other than that i've been really
productive this week i know you find
this sort of boring but i find it
exciting but i cleared out the whole
office i shredded so much paperwork that
we had that always scares me though when
you say you've shredded stuff yeah
what's ready reason to have to sh well
because it's confidential there's lots
of lots and lots of stuff bought some
files from amazon like organized
everything really like perfect adulting
and like you know productiveness so i
feel really proud i feel like i've
achieved a lot this week
and i've had a pretty much stay-at-home
week i've just been literally i've been
in so many events and viewing properties
and driving all around the country i
decided to just shut myself away for a
week and deal with emails catching up
having some thinking time and also
watching some tv
oh yeah people think that millionaires
get up every morning at 5am
and never watch anything
on the tv in fact i don't really watch
tv so much but we do watch netflix a
little bit yeah we do we do it's like a
bit of a chill out kind of um kind of
thing so it's been quite quite quite
chilled i'm in rest i'm in rest mode
right now also we're looking so
bright i know i don't know what i don't
know what's changed today but for
cameras it's it's just like yeah i don't
know if it's good or not why do you like
it
i look like a snowman
[Laughter]
my eyes are very blue so um so yes
that's what we've been doing so this
week we're gonna be taking your
questions and we're gonna be answering
your questions around money marriage or
life um so go ahead and ask your
anything you wanted to know about me
about amanda no matter how personal it
might be ask away what kind of questions
would you ask if you were there
well whatever you think you ask like if
you want to get to know us a bit more
you might ask like i don't know what's
our favorite kind of music
where do you like to go on holiday
what books would you recommend i don't
know what restaurants what series tv
series we'd recommend what do we like to
watch
and while you are asking away in the
comments i'm gonna ask i'm answer some
of my own questions and feel free amanda
you can ask me stuff as well but i wanna
know in the news some things that have
been going on the news i know we try and
keep the saturday podcast away from
property but i'm really interested in
your opinion on this um and that is
they are talking about banning
by buying a second home
for
um
in fact let me let me get the the news
article you know like you know when
people buy properties in holiday holiday
areas yeah they're talking about banning
that because they're saying that um it's
ruining some villagers because lots of
millionaires like when we went to
sandbanks and all these millionaires
have got all these empty houses that
they have as their second home but don't
really go there
ruining the community it's ruining so
the um the councils are talking about
potentially banning second homes this is
breaking news it just came out today i
don't know what you think well i just
think that's crazy because i mean maybe
just thinking from our perspective if we
did have a holiday home somewhere most
people now rent their homes out on
airbnb which would bring tourists and
more people to the area anyway so i
can't see why
that would be an issue another thing
that they're saying there as well is
it's pushing the price up really high
because all these um poor villagers that
actually live there yeah are getting
priced out by
second home holiday makers london
millionaires well it's a shame that's a
shame but i don't think i don't get why
people should be penalized like if you
happen to have enough money to buy a
second home like why why should you not
be allowed that
i just uh ministers preparing crackdown
on second homes and could give councils
free reign to ban outsiders from new
properties that seems so strange i just
don't understand like the rationale or
the thinking behind it yeah i disagree
with it
yeah well that's that then what do you
think let us know in the comments some
of the some of the comments on the daily
mail are uh someone said ask yourself
how many mps have a second home
it's a good question
need all those extra houses for our
afghan friends
i can understand it a little bit from
the villager's point of view
imagine that you
were
you grew up in a village your parents
lived there your grandparents lived
there
and suddenly
both sides of your neighbors
the house is just empty
but is the house taken care of
yes
so what's the issue
it's true
if it's like if you live in next door to
property that's just becoming coming to
like rack and ruin and no one's looking
after it that's a different issue but
just because someone who doesn't happen
to live in your area full-time bought
your house i don't see why that should
be a problem it will push the prices up
though with lots of people but then
that's kind of what happens when you
live in a beautiful area with the sea
yeah i know it just is what it is i
don't think it will ever change it's
just like when people that are born and
bred in london complain about that sort
of thing it's just like well it just is
what it is like complaining about it
isn't gonna change it okay
talking of complaining about stuff next
news story i today a few hours ago got
the most popular comment on i'm just
bait video oh my gosh i know highlight
of my week i can't believe it he had
like over ten thousand yeah i know ten
thousand people liked my comment which
is more
likes
than
probably i get on all of my youtube
videos put together over an entire month
it's crazy yeah a lot 10 000 people
liked my comment um so the comment was
about someone complaining you don't like
complainers do you no i don't it was
someone complaining about the logan paul
situation why don't you just talk a
little bit about what happened the guy
asking for a job and basically a guy
quit his job flew over to l.a and then
he snuck into an event and he wanted to
speak to logan paul and then he goes up
to logan paul and he says look i've quit
my job i'm basically looking for a job
can you give me a break i want to work
for you and logan's just like look mate
i'm not the guy
and then the guy's like i need a mentor
and then he's like look i need logan's
like i need a mentor like i'm not in the
position to to be that person to you
right now and then he just gives him
some sound business advice life advice
and then he just wishes him all the best
and then he's like i need to go
i don't think that he was rude i think
that he was actually quite nice it's the
newspaper headlines though and they're
like oh logan paul crushed this young
man yeah
he's like did he really this is what i
said this was my popular comment it's
actually said ten and a half thousand
now and counting wow
i just said logan was very nice to him
and offered good advice he is suffering
a little from entitlement nobody owes
him anything and i'm talking about the
guy that was going crazy he was crying
yeah he said but i've left my job though
to come and work for you and logan was
just like well no one asked you to do
that oh i know it's really really
strange but i almost feel like the guy
just made the video
just for attention because at the
beginning of the video he's like crying
and he's all upset but i don't even
understand why he's crying and trust me
i get emotional so i can understand when
i get i get when you get emotional you
start crying but this guy was crying i
feel like he just had no reason to be
crying it was just like do you think do
you think it kind of links though to the
last story we're talking about about
entitlement it's almost like you can't
come and have a second home in my
village this is my village this is my
it's almost like this sense of almost
like you own every house in the village
you don't you own your house or
entitlement to you owe me a job because
i it's like really yeah and you know i
think entitlement is really the thing
that will keep people poor um so you
know love to know what you think in fact
in fact we'll we'll play the logan paul
clip right now and then you can comment
on your thoughts below in the comment
box before i approached him he was
bragging about making three million
dollars
i make a hundred thousand dollars a year
22 i do make a hundred thousand that's
cool and i wanna
i wanna act i wanna i wanna do these
things
i'm gonna break down go make content do
stuff with your friends i'm glad you
quit your job it takes balls to do that
bro but like now you got to actually try
to make a step i'm the idea but i'm not
the guy directly you're definitely
you're the guy you're the guy bro my
team is
this
i'm not the guy like you know life isn't
about handouts you know what i'm saying
i know i'm just trying to hand out i'm
not trying to get what are you trying to
do i'm trying to work hard for a little
money no money i don't know i can get a
job somewhere else all i want to move to
la and i want to i want to be able to be
part of that look i have to go if you
really are serious about it bro you
should move to la and just like you
approach me start making connections
with every single person you know i'm
serious i've always said this if you
have if you're charismatic
it is now time to answer some questions
from the subscribers
so um i've picked a few questions
comment your questions below but in the
meantime we have got um somebody has
asked
would we ever buy
where we live
and i think the reason that's been asked
is because i'm very vocal about the fact
that it makes more sense to rent where
you live and then rent out what you own
um why don't you just talk a little bit
about that and then maybe touch on
whether we ever would buy and what the
rationale behind that would be
okay well what we do is that we have
lots of property and then then we can
just rent wherever we want um
we don't want to be tied down anywhere
at the moment we're kind of just open to
living wherever we want to live i feel
like we're quite young if we think we
want to move here we want to be able to
just do it um without being tied to
anywhere but um i think in the future we
probably will buy
a forever home
or maybe even build who knows but i
think we're not opposed to it i think i
think at some point we will but i just
don't see the point in taking all that
capital and then tying it up in a house
that we're going to be living in what
were the reasons that we would do it
though because at some point it probably
will yeah so when the kids are going to
school saying we found an area that we
love and we know that we're going to be
staying there for a long long time for
me i would only buy
a house to live in if
that investment if it was almost like
sofa change you know money down the side
of the sofa like what i'm against is
people when i can't step i'm against for
us
is starting out in life and spending all
of your time and energy to try and raise
a deposit to buy a house to live in and
then get that mortgage paid off as
quickly as possible meanwhile you're
working in a job you don't own any
assets the house that you live in is not
an asset it doesn't pay you any money
it's a liability
however if you've got loads of assets
and you're making lots of money and then
you think ah i fancy buying a house to
live in that's no problem but just
accept that it's not a good commercial
decision and just make sure that it
doesn't hurt you to do it it's just like
you don't even miss the money then maybe
consider buying
make sense make sense
um okay got a question from megan and
megan dawson she says i was wondering if
you could help me out it's my
boyfriend's 21st birthday
next week and i was wondering if you
could do him a video birthday message
his name is sam
collier um no i'm not prepared to do a
shout out
i'm just kidding i actually she's
actually done a pic she's sent me a
picture of me and sam and i actually
know this dude i remember meeting him at
least one occasion um here is sam
collier whose birthday it is next week
so sam massive congratulations for
meeting me and taking a picture but even
more so
for having your 21st birthday coming up
next week you know big respect hope to
see you again real soon and uh maybe
you'll be sat on this sofa in a couple
years and we'll be discussing your
winners on a wednesday story i look
forward to that but have a wonderful
birthday and uh much love and god bless
to you and to megan do you want to add
anything to that happy birthday sam have
a good one okay um amanda
why did you not get the tesla i am very
disappointed i love tesla sorry i just
don't like how they look like a
spaceship they just don't look like a
normal car and i say normal but yeah i
just didn't fancy the look of it but
maybe in the future i will but i'm
really happy with my mercedes so another
another one um his wife
that means amanda
his wife looked pissed when he called
his camera lady beautiful
oh really
when was this
that was just a comment um that is which
videos that are do you want to see it
show the receipts all right i'll show
you the video
uh this is it
that sounds really strange
here we go they would have been talking
about amelia as well and i love
so we're here sat down on the sofa about
to collect the rent to rank keys the
beautiful lady sarah he's got a great
voice but hasn't got a makeup on so it
doesn't want to be on the camera um
i don't think i look pissed off i don't
understand i think it was just the way
your eyes went you continued to smile
but your eyes just like looked a bit
we're here sat down on the sofa about to
collect the rent keys the beautiful lady
sarah he's got a great voice but
i don't even remember i don't even know
who that who we're talking about but nah
i don't think i was you can safely say
you weren't pissed off that wasn't this
stuff i don't i don't remember being
pissed because i wasn't actually talking
about the camera lady i was talking
about we we me and amanda secured a rent
to rent and the lady who gave us the
rent to rent
i wanted to do a video about it because
i film everything that i do
and she didn't want me to film so i said
i'll keep you out of it but then as i
was talking to her i thought she might
think
that the audience assumed that she's
really ugly because she doesn't want to
be on camera so i was like all the
beautiful um let just gave us the rent
around who doesn't want to be on camera
right now because she's not going to
make upon but when i said the beautiful
lady amanda's eyes just kind of went
like this
i don't even think they did but
interesting interesting observation
there people really read into stuff that
i know yeah
we watched um i think didn't we recently
about is it bad just to call people not
beautiful um like darling love oh yeah
patronizing is it bad when you go
somewhere and they call the men sir and
the women darling then i think hold on a
minute if you're going to be nice and
respectful to him why not give me that
why not call me madam if he's and i must
be madame surely that's something
i'm going to tell you this now and i go
shopping a great deal
i have never heard somebody's hello sir
hello darling are you talking tripe do
you make sure you're going along uh
you're from the north of the country i'm
from the north and everyone says like
how you pair i love no i don't i don't
find it offensive at all but apparently
some women do so you probably didn't
even think i was being flirtatious or
anything no no no no it's just it's kind
of a northern thing
i don't really do it these days i think
especially if i'm like in a professional
setting i don't think i'd call somebody
dear or love or unless i knew them quite
well i would call them
i actually don't know what i would call
them i would call them you hey
no because who was the lady she was
saying oh why is it that people call me
love all the time but then a man will
get called sir
yeah and it's like
the person that would call someone says
not the same person that would call
someone love
i just don't think sir it's just not
that's true yeah that's true again let
us know in the comments is it offensive
to call somebody dear darling love is
that offensive or is it just northern
anyway um drop your comments below drop
your thoughts below we're gonna be back
next week i hope you enjoyed the videos
i hope you enjoyed this little
conversation and um don't forget to hit
the like button remember it doesn't cost
anything to like the video so do it now
what the heck
it's free and subscribe we'll see you
guys next time thanks for watching guys
bye
[Music]